hi everyone
well charlie and jenny and i have been
you know talking about relationships
valentine's day and um i would like to
ask you
um
scott have you ever been dumped
okay i dumped first
and i wanted back
get back
um i can't help it but i'm such a fan of
your dad i'm sorry i know you hear that
all the time but i love your dad so much
and
never heard that clint eastwood and i
met him once and i talk about him all
the time on the show because i met him
and i met him in las vegas and of course
i was like oh my god i love you so much
i love you i've loved you my whole life
i love you i love you i love you and he
looked at me went
it's my favorite story ever well look we
can be friends
give you my number when this ends we can
be friends i'm coming over
um clark have you ever been dumped
yes i
you know what though
i was dumped and it was so brutal and
then a few months later he came back and
i actually took him back and then i
dumped him a few years later
was it scott
[Applause]
no
no it's
but no
um gina i am such a huge fan of yours
and i i i just am and i have been for
years
and i'm so
honored to be talking to you right now
and i understand that your husband has
like a certain love language is this
true
oh he we all do right definitely but he
does yeah he is
i mean he
i am very lucky because my love language
is acts of service and my husband
really supports me in that and helps me
in all the ways he's pretty magical
um
is it true like that he also like cleans
am i wrong in this information no you're
not wrong in this information dishes are
like i get really really nauseous when i
do dishes and he has known that for many
years and so i've been off the hook for
the majority of our relationship it's
also just sexy when i mean god how many
years of women complain about men not
you know lifting a finger and your man
is you know
good
and he does it shirtless so
yes
yes
[Applause]
well manny i mean you have become this
most sought-after gentleman in hollywood
i was just watching nine perfect
strangers you're so good in that
and the good place
and now this
how are you feeling about the characters
you've been playing and is there
something you haven't played yet that
you really want to play
um i want to do anything and everything
um i would love to do let's i mean can
we just do another i want you back
sequel can we get like a i want you back
again yeah
i think it's so great and i just i
really love it and i think it's amazing
and our whole audience is going home
with the movie to watch
at the end of the show
um now if you will to end i was
wondering if you guys would do a final
six are you up for it
yeah yeah yeah all right here we go
thank you
charlie how do you feel open uh about
getting uh back with an x or all sales
are final oh man all sales are final
don't walk out on this guy because we
are done
all right i like it
um jenny the best song to run to your
lover in an airport
yes
thank you you're that's why you're
getting asleep um okay
scott have you ever uh drunk texted an
ex yes
yes i love it
gina what's your favorite rom-com
the wedding singer no
i'm not josie grossie anymore i'm not
just grossy anymore
[Applause]
and yet i am
i'll come over scott and i'll do that
for your dad especially he'll love that
he's gonna love josie grossi
manny have you ever been in a love
triangle or a hexagon like him i want
you back
only in fictional situations
it's always in fictional situations for
now yeah clark what is your favorite
rom-com cliche
i think you already named it though i
think it's the run at the airport
because it doesn't make no it doesn't
make any sense you actually can't run to
get someone at the airport
not anymore
and yet we are still telling these
stories because we will always be trying
to master the art of relationships
because that is what life is about it is
love
so
thank you jenny slate charlie j scott
eastwood gina rodriguez and manny
jacinto and clark bacco thank you all
for showing up today thank you for
talking about this wonderful movie i
want you back is available to stream
starting today on amazon prime
[Music]